hey guys Dave and Gina we are back at
the kitchen table Roseanne's kitchen
table if you want to find out what the
hell we're doing here
click on the annotation right above and
I'm very excited because we're at
Roseanne's kitchen table one of my
favorite sitcoms of all time we're gonna
talk about another sitcom right now we
have our coffee right here as you can
see but we should have cheesecake that
would have been more appropriate next
time we're gonna do this with some
cheesecake should be in frilly Hynek
night guess we should have giant
shoulder pads do you see where we're
going with this people I wanted to talk
about the Golden Girls because I tweet
about the Golden Girls a lot everyone
knows I love the Golden Girls and people
always ask me why do I love the Golden
Girls so much and we talked about this
one yeah we talked about last night yeah
so there's not many reasons just funny
number one so that's I would because if
things with people make shows no matter
how many what you say whatever you make
a political statement right if it's not
funny at the end of the day nobody cares
so funny number one incredible actresses
number two the powerful stuff that they
did number three in terms of gay rights
and abortion and aging and older people
having sex and I mean just the endless
I've talked a lot so far what why do you
yeah first of all first and foremost for
me personally because the first time I
ever sat at the foot of my mom's bed
which is was my Golden Girls viewing
spot every night at ten o'clock yeah Bea
Arthur looked very very much like my
grandmother and so when I was really
little I thought that grandma's just
this is what they do when you're not
with them they go on sitcoms I thought
that was my grandma literally yes we are
so i felt very connected to it right
away cuz i said that's great
that's grandma that's incredible so yes
she's amazing
so but as i've gotten older and as we
see so many shows and you know WB and CW
in winter whatever those exist anymore
i don't know and an HBO go but everyone
is so terrified that they're not going
to be looked at in a proper light
they're literally and figuratively
yeah and to see these broads just do
whatever they have to do as long as it
serves the show and serves the comedy is
there anything greater than that and
doesn't even exist anymore well don't
you miss that time that like period
obviously I to me the heyday and maybe
it's because I grew up in it but that
heyday of like midday
to mid-90s there were so many great
shows and they were really tackling
issues and did it in a funny way that
showed particularly because the
actresses were for like perfect
powerhouses and I'm sure I'm sure I'm
not dead telling you I don't know you
know Betty White was not supposed to be
rose I know
duh Betty White was supposed to be
Blanche right and then she said that she
didn't want to basically reprise the
whole role of Mary Tyler Moore thank God
because roo-roo nailed it yeah there's
also something about the way that they
tape the shows now that I don't think
works like when you watch some of those
shows on TV land now there something
about a sitcom shot in those old cameras
that didn't look as perfect now like
when you watch something in perfect HD
these actors it starts looking like
television you imagine being high-def
that would be you're gonna be smirch be
no I don't look good in hi-def and I got
the she had 30 years on me then yeah do
you ever do you have a moment or a
episode or a clip that was like really
doesn't work because I've got one I've
got one that to me sums up the
brilliance of the whole show there's so
many I the two actually comes to mind
one is very heartfelt and one's just low
when Sophie you think she's having a
heart attack and in the middle of the
storm and it's very gut-wrenching and it
I think I cry every time I see it but
who doesn't love when all the gals
gather around the piano and sing Miami
you gotta stop that's the greatest thing
ever
yeah that's a good one yet did you want
to get the one more that was those do I
thought that was a flashback one when
she was dying or saying so my favorite
to me this is so brilliant and it sums
up everything why it was so funny and
culturally irrelevant and edgy too
that's the part that was edgy so there
was an episode where Blanche's brother
Clayton was gay yep he came out in one
episode but there was a second episode
where he was gonna get married to this
guy Doug now this is Florida in 1991
Florida still does not have gay marriage
now in 2014 many many years later and
later I'm not a fan of all this Blanche
was not a fan but she started coming
around right and and Blanche says 1991 9
P
on NBC the joke she says - uh she says -
Clayton well why do you want to marry
Doug and he says well I'd do anything
for Doug and he bend over backwards for
me
they made a gay anal sex reference on
NBC in 1991 like how subversive and
brilliant and because it was funny and
it said something if I realize that NBC
was the sodomy network's oh they were
huge on sodomy bad idea yeah now of
course it's more of the ABCs in the CBS
right anyway so yes clearly we love the
Golden Girls do you have a favorite
sitcom I hope it's the Golden Girls but
I also accept Roseanne and The Cosby
Show although now that Cosby
I can't let's just go out on the lanai
and take a break okay very good
subscribe comment all that good stuff